Nueva Zelanda es un extraordinario país de
poco más de cuatro millones y medio de habitantes
y una superficie de doscientos sesenta y ocho
mil kilómetros cuadrados, algo menos que
la de Japón o la de Italia. Situado en el
Pacífico Sur, se puede decir que Nueva Zelanda
está, literalmente, lejos de todo, y es que,
aunque viendo los mapas tengamos la sensación
de que está junto a Australia, les separan,
en el mejor de los casos, algo más de 1.600Km.
Gracias a ello podemos encontrar especies
endémicas tan simpáticas como el kiwi, un
ave nocturna que no vuela, y que es el autentico
símbolo nacional.
A pesar de ser un país tan aislado, Nueva
Zelanda ha conseguido convertirse, con un
modelo único, en uno de los países con mayor
nivel de vida del mundo. En este primer vídeo
sobre la tierra de los kiwis, te contamos
alguna de las claves más llamativas de su
éxito.
Si alguno habéis estado allí sabréis que
podemos considerar a Nueva Zelanda como la
tierra de la alegría, la simpatía y la calidad
de vida. Os aseguro, por experiencia propia,
que no exagero, hablamos de una tierra de
acogida, donde 1 de cada 4 habitantes ha nacido
en el extranjero, y donde incluso la lengua
de signos tiene el rango de lengua oficial.
Y lo cierto es que sus ciudadanos tienen muchos
motivos para estar más que contentos y satisfechos:
Nueva Zelanda es uno de los cinco países
más seguros del mundo, su economía es la
tercera más libre de todo el planeta, y según
el ranking doing business es el segundo país
donde más fácil es hacer negocios.
Además, por si esto fuera poco, es considerado
como el cuarto país menos corrupto del mundo,
hay más empleo que en la media de los países
de la OCDE al y cuenta con sistemas educativos,
sanitarios y culturales excelentes. Es decir,
Nueva Zelanda es a todas luces un éxito económico,
social y de integración.
Pero dejando todo esto aun lado, en este vídeo
nos vamos a centrar en una de las claves de
su éxito y a la postre uno de sus rasgos
más característicos: el campo.
Nueva Zelanda es el único país desarrollado
donde el sector primario ha ganado peso en
las tres últimas décadas, representando
hoy casi el siete por ciento de su economía
de forma directa. Por comparar, cabe destacar
que en el caso de la Unión Europea el peso
del sector primario es del uno coma seis por
ciento del PIB, cuatro veces menos que en
Nueva Zelanda. Incluso el poco más del 2%
de una potencia agrícola como es España
se antoja ridículo al lado de Nueva Zelanda.
No hay un caso equivalente en todo el mundo.
Por ejemplo, la leche y los productos lácteos
son la mayor exportación de Nueva Zelanda,
y sumando sus diferentes conceptos, el sector
primario y la industria agroalimentaria representan
casi el 60% de todas las exportaciones comerciales
del país. ¿Podíais imaginar que el campo
fuese uno de los motores principales de uno
de los países con mayor bienestar y nivel
de vida del mundo?
La competitividad del campo neozelandes es
tal que, además, la consigue sin subvenciones
de por medio. Por ejemplo, cada año la Unión
Europea reparte subvenciones a los agricultores
y ganaderos por un importe que equivale a
cerca del 20% del valor de su producción.
Tan solo en España, la Unión Europea tiene
previsto desembolsar entre 2014 y 2020 la
friolera de 47.000 millones de euros, en ayudas
al campo. En Nueva Zelanda, en cambio, las
ayudas se quedan en 0,7% del valor de producción
– 27 veces menos que en la Unión Europea
-y el gasto está enfocado sobre todo a investigación
e innovación.
El ahorro es, como vemos, sustancial.
- El "Rogernomics" y la revolución agrícola
neozelandesa.
Ahora bien, esta situación no fue siempre
así. A principios de los años ochenta, cerca
del cuarenta por ciento de los ingresos de
las explotaciones agrícolas y ganaderas de
Nueva Zelanda correspondían a subvenciones
del gobierno. Por aquel entonces la economía
neozelandesa era un ejemplo de proteccionismo,
y como consecuencia de ello atravesaba una
dura crisis: el déficit público era enorme,
casi el diez por ciento del PIB, había una
inflación de dos dígitos, la deuda exterior
no paraba de crecer, el desempleo aumentaba
y la economía estaba estancada.
- "Ya ha pasado un mes, ¿por qué no crece
algo?.
En este contexto, en 1984, el Ministro de
Economía del recién elegido gobierno laborista,
Roger Douglas, impulsó un ambicioso paquete
de reformas – conocido como rogernomics
– que liberalizaba muchos ámbitos de la
economía y que en el sector primario pasaba
por eliminar los controles de precios y suprimir
la mayoría de los subsidios y ayudas públicas
al campo. Además, para combatir la inflación
el gobierno subió los tipos de interés lo
que enfrentó a ganaderos y agricultores,
que habían asumido muchas deudas en los años
precedentes, a la tormenta perfecta: caída
de ingresos, más gastos en intereses de la
deuda y un desplome en el valor de la tierra.
Así que ya os podéis imaginar que la transición
no fue del todo fácil.
- "Hare las letrinas" - "Arrancaré las malas
hierbas" -" Y yo reprimiré lo que siento"
- "Así me gusta, ¡que comience la agricultura!"
Pero pronto aparecieron los beneficios que
conllevaba poner fin a las subvenciones:
La pérdida de ingresos estimuló a los agricultores
a buscar innovaciones que incrementasen el
valor de la producción introduciendo nuevos
cultivos, mejorando la calidad y apostando
por métodos más ecológicos, al tiempo que
controlaban estrictamente los costes.
Ya no se trataba de maximizar la producción
de los productos subvencionados sino de mejorar
la cadena de valor, orientarse a los consumidores
y reducir costes. Por ejemplo, la subvención
de los fertilizantes se había traducido en
un uso indiscriminado de los mismos.
- "Aquí es donde empaquetamos ¿sabe? Y lo
que hacemos es que las galletas tengan un
maravilloso aroma, un aroma natural y fresco
¿comprende? Y se consigue con un pulverizador
químico."
Cuando la subvención terminó el consumo
de fertilizantes se desplomó, sin que ello
afectase a la producción. Los granjeros aprendieron
a utilizarlos solo en casos necesarios, lo
que además de reducir los costes de producción
tuvo un efecto muy positivo sobre el medio
ambiente. Lo mismo ocurrió con todos los
inputs.
Respecto a los nuevos cultivos y productos
podemos destacar el impresionante desarrollo
que ha tenido, por ejemplo, la industria del
vino, donde la superficie de viñedos se ha
prácticamente triplicado en la última década
y sus vinos se han convertido ya en referencia
mundial.
Asimismo, con el objetivo de encontrar nuevas
fuentes de ingresos, la población de los
entornos rurales comenzó a desarrollar negocios
complementarios como es el caso del turismo
rural y los productos agroalimentarios elaborados,
en ambos casos muy dependientes de la conservación
del entorno y la construcción de una marca
bien valorada.
De esta forma, los propios agricultores y
ganaderos comenzaron a realizar importantes
esfuerzos encaminados a la protección del
medio ambiente.
El resultado fue impresionante. Al final solo
ochocientas explotaciones, el uno por ciento
fueron liquidadas y en los veinte años posteriores
a mil novecientos ochenta y seis, la producción
del sector creció un cuarenta por ciento.
Desde que se eliminaron los subsidios el sector
creció más que la economía general, y entre
1986 y 2006 tuvo un crecimiento sostenido
del cinco coma nueve por ciento anual ¡Casi
nada! También fue relevante la apuesta por
la internacionalización, que ha conducido
a que hoy el campo neozelandés exporte competitivamente
más del noventa por ciento de su producción.
¡Y encima han mejorado el medio ambiente!
Nueva Zelanda es un ejemplo de cómo las subvenciones
y las malas políticas dañan la innovación,
la diversificación y la productividad, al
tiempo que, por supuesto, se convierten en
un lastre para las cuentas públicas. Así,
es el caso de la PAC, la proteccionista política
agraria de la Unión Europea, que nos cuesta
a los miembros de la unión la friolera de
50.000 millones cada año.
- "Hemos acordado que 150 millones es una
ofensa, no aceptamos menos de 150 mil millones."
Frente a ello, Nueva Zelanda nos muestra que,
haciendo bien las cosas, podemos ahorrar mucho
dinero al tiempo que mejoramos la situación
de las áreas rurales. Los neozelandeses han
derribado el mito de que la agricultura no
puede prosperar sin subvenciones.
Para los que conocéis España, imaginad el
enorme potencial que podrían tener regiones
como Cantabria, Asturias, Galicia o Extremadura.
- "Los ganaderos alertan de que el sector
primario de Cantabria se va a la ruina."
Y desde luego, los gobiernos latinoamericanos
también deberían tomar nota y apostar por
la capitalización del campo.
Y es que mientras en Nueva Zelanda tienen
como objetivo duplicar sus exportaciones agrícolas
para 2025, aquí seguimos pensando prácticamente
solo en repartir más y más subvenciones.
¿Qué pensáis vosotros? ¿Creéis que sin
ayudas el campo se moriría? ¿Es posible
replicar el éxito de Nueva Zelanda? Espero
que os haya gustado este vídeo, si ha sido
así darle a like y suscribiros al canal
si aún no lo habéis hecho ya. Un saludo
y hasta el próximo vídeo.